hello welcome to simulation I'm your
host Alan sockin and today we're sitting
down with Nathaniel Miller it's great to
be here thank you so much this is a
pleasure it's a great pleasure we're in
Napa at dent you can find them dent the
future it's an amazing conference full
of brilliant people we've have the
pleasure of working together here and
attending it's a blast
so if you're not familiar simulation
pairs together global leaders with
humanity's most thought-provoking
questions and we're on patreon so if you
find this content useful of course give
it a like if it a comment give us a
subscribe and furthermore if you want to
get some of our membership benefit so
you can get access to exclusive content
you can get priority and asking our
guests questions you can know who our
guests are ahead of time and get access
to live events ahead of time as well and
location and guess it info all that good
stuff so do consider becoming a member
and telling others about this as well so
well we're gonna go ahead and dive right
into it this so the sun is shining or
all over our bodies feel so good alright
so we were chatting a bit yesterday and
it was really cool how your perspective
on what the word govern mm-hm
yeah and we had a good conversation
about it maybe we try and highlight some
of those cool thoughts that we had about
it what does govern meets you why is it
important well the the perspective that
it's coming from is also really
important I'm not you know I don't study
policy and
I don't really there's a lot I don't
know about what it means to govern I'm a
mechanical and electrical engineer who
started out building houses with my dad
in one neighbor gave me a lawnmower and
the other neighbor asked me to mow their
grass and then I told my dad we had a
problem I think we had built maybe 10 or
15 maybe 10 or 15 houses by then and
this is by the time you're 17 or so I
was 15 at that time 16 maybe and then by
the time I was 18 I had to stop my very
successful landscaping company to go to
be an electrical mechanical engineer not
knowing that that's the way it would
turn out and and I ended up you know
when you think about robotics you think
about like mechatronics there's
mechanical electrical system and
software runs it right so so the thing
that defines the software is the control
system and so it's almost like you know
it's like we make we take the dirt and
we like shape it and they get like
Sparks and bolts and put the robot
together and then we breathe into it
software it comes alive you know and and
we create things in the same capacity
that we written we have this like
creation capacity we have were created
to create things yes
right and so that's like when you when
you're asking me the question of
governance that's really good I mean the
knothole in the world that I'm coming
from mm-hmm having made a lot of you
know I need platforms for science
instruments for a long time and that's
the interface between the platform maybe
if it's got wheels wings or solar panels
that's the thing that carries the
instrument to the point of curiosity no
pun intended with Mars
yes not my project to do a scientific
inquiry and so so I've kind of grown up
in that building platforms understanding
the instrument and really building
missions now across the science value
chain that's that's what's the need that
science is meeting what's the instrument
that delivers the observation what's the
platform that delivers the instrument
and then what's the data that comes from
that system to give us the measurement
that lets us do the science so that's
what when we talk about governance
that's where I'm coming from
you speak about it from such a technical
perspective I love the software yeah
into the mechanic yeah yeah that whole
thing right and there's and there's
there's there's hearts and minds that
envision what that thing ought to be and
then we create the thing yeah and then
it does what we designed it to do or not
but that's the art right yeah yeah so
yeah so when you ask governance I'm
thinking about the people that are
designing these complex systems for
scientific inquiry that's where I've
come from so it's the governance simply
from my perspective is it's the capacity
to exert influence far beyond your
actions so I'm doing something for the
common good as well for the common good
yeah it's before the common good so it's
it's I'm doing something here it has an
influence and it has an effect and I
wouldn't actually say good or bad that's
a judgement statement uh-huh it's just
an effect an effect so I'm having an
influence yeah beyond it's a direct
influence a limiting or enabling
influence beyond what I do right now
now then you can ask the question do we
no good governor or bad governor's
there's a good government or a bad
government and those are value judgments
that as an engineer I much prefer to say
is effective or not and then is it
effective for what
and that really sidesteps a lot of the
medical problems I live and work in a
political organization to do engineering
you will need to be very clear and
concise and understanding you know it's
not it's not a partisan issue governance
is not a partisan issue you know like
the way we like government the way the
way we use government as a tool is an
enabler right and and and there's and
and the the politics is the conversation
around whether how to approach that
governance problem
I'm set from the controls guy you asked
me what governance is what do I do that
projects influence beyond my reach yes
yes that's a really interesting way to
look at it now so you have experience
with Co fest the Congress of future
engineering software yeah and also NASA
and so with so you have about 18 years
of Kofi and 13 years of NASA and you're
at Langley in Virginia and so this also
adds a yeah this adds a whole this gives
us background on how you think really
deep understanding how you think cuz
that's why you spoke in such a way on
governance so how do we then come up
with some sort of a this is what's
happened over the last let's say 250
years in the United States so let's take
what we really enjoyed from that and add
a couple we've we have been a amending
along the way but then how do we build
for the future what do we do we have
some goal congruence in designing the
system and building it for the future do
we have global congruence where do you
kind of question I should take shorter
time answering maybe the questions would
be easier so I think so there's kind of
like a couple questions in there one
what is Co fast right so the Congress on
the future of engineering saw fit
software in what what does my story have
to relate to Virginia and and my view in
governance and kind of where that comes
from I think that might be that let's do
it that is first chunk Lesotho so the
Congress on the future of engineering
software is well well you know it starts
like this there's that there's a
visionary journalist and a data junkie
show up in an industry and they say hey
what should we do now it turns out that
this industry as we know it today is
where computer-aided design you know
like like an inventor a kind of a tool
or Assad works or you know CATIA there's
different all these geometry software's
that design stuff right so it's that
industry that industry is 20 or 30 years
old 20 25 to 35 years old depending on
age
- and and the Congress on the future of
engineering software was a was it was it
was a conversation that was designed and
started very very similar to the purpose
of debt to bring sort of diverse and
competing views into conversation in a
constructive way
yeah yeah and so the so the data the the
journalist was a guy named Evan the data
junkie was the guy named Brad and the
visionary was a guy named Joel
Joel's my grandfather and and and I've
grown up there Soko Fez we just had our
20th year yesterday I'm saying yesterday
thank God the Syrian people get to
Virginia don't know why I said that we
just had in 2017 that was our it was our
20th event and we've just stood up the
Kofi's Institute to carry on that
functionality as engineering software
grows out to influence the things the
design of the things that they're made
that shaped the world yeah so somebody
has a tool that tool designs a product
that product makes it into the hands of
thousands millions maybe billions of
people and that a billion of anything
has an effect and so so these tools
design those products and have an effect
on the world so SoCo Fez has shaped has
had a shaping hand I've seen just so
many I just go on for an hour probably
of the world's shaping effects that I
have seen in that Congress on the future
so for example when you go to
Thingiverse it lists like 35 different
files that you can upload to right now
it's not true
more advanced software is probably like
three different files you can maybe five
or something like that from all these
different CAD programs right that went
back in the day when I started using CAD
software it was not a forgone assumption
that I can make geometry here and have
it show up in that software that was not
that just didn't how right like that
I watched that get healed over a decade
I watched through that when the
conversation started in the mid 90s and
by the time we got to the mid 2000s that
Congress that that issue had entire
and that's a crucial crucial crucial
crucial i've also saw the segmenting of
the industry like where people it was
the place where people could come and
understand with you know if they're
looking at the future there's awful lot
we don't know about the future but one
thing is we know it's all made up of
what we see today okay no like we're
gonna be right here in five minutes and
i get got a word for you there's
something coming in the future and it's
right here in five minutes right we
don't know what it's gonna be but it's
gonna have to do with you and me right
so so i also watch the industry segment
similarly where we had these characters
playing all these companies and
governances and companies and media like
all the and and and the segmenting
happens when you have deep trust in
extreme competition in other words i i
know what you're interested in and i'm
just not going to tell you about my
strategy but we're gonna still have a
relationship yeah and so I grew up
watching these c-level executives build
and grow relationships that ultimately
moved the industry why doesn't PTC you
know like PTC and SolidWorks are really
like the creo product and the solvers I
watched that segmenting of markets as
they sort of moved after different
profit different market sectors just by
being around the the few people that are
leading those in dish that industry and
then it's back to the conversation of
governance because I know that's where
you were going
it's a conversation it's a conversation
so so so to bring it to relevance today
let's take it back to 50 or 15:12
we're on a field team twelve fifteen
twelve and maybe just before we go back
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah summarize okay
please do my best to get this in so we
are then taking what is able to be made
by people's minds their vision and we're
using this amazing computer-aided design
software yes you make the actual math on
binary yeah on a computer and then from
there we can test it digitally yeah
these simulations to see how it's gonna
hold up in the real world before we
build it yeah and then we start the
actual process of building it into the
world yep and so then that is such a
crucial
component for what we build into the
future and then you were also discussing
about the importance of people at the
high level maybe not revealing their
their most important strategic points
but still being able to communicate with
one another about the futures of the
building and the importance of that yeah
so communication is up here a trust is
right here yeah and so it was the
communication not just in the words but
also in the in the friendship across the
industry to grow and really and really
shape how that looked right okay yeah
yeah so so so the other the other the
other thing that that really goes there
is that you know when these leaders come
together they the conversations that
like like the the thing that dent is
really holding a tradition that Kofi's
really carried is a degenerative
conversation I'm not coming to a
question that okay so you're on that
side I'm on this side of us all right
we've clearly we can't be friends right
you know we see that I think that's
where that I'd like to just draw the
line to relevance and that experience
for me where I'd actually seen it and so
this will say to everybody watching
everybody watching the show is I've
actually seen it work in my lifetime I'm
30 33 years old and I've seen it work in
my lifetime where where people come
together with radically different
motivations direct competition radically
different views and and really heal to
to to to a cohesive view and and that
that's that's kind of the part that
traces back to 1512 right okay and as we
go there I need a touch on that because
that is so much of what we do with what
our mission and passion vision is all
about is being able to have these tough
conversations even though sometimes
people disagree but being able to stay
even keel and not could become super
angry or frustrated or sad or hyper
excited but just stay chill and still be
able to converse with somebody that has
a different perspective and maybe take
some of what they say with your
open-mindedness and implement some of it
into your worldview as well
and amazing amazing yes okay 15:12
not a chill day yeah 1512 is not she's
not sure not sure King of England has
big problems because he's trying to be a
king and everybody is really really
frustrated with how he's being a king
there's a lot more to it read it in the
history books because they're still
there go so really seriously go out and
check what happened in 1512 and and the
document that was that was a result
there was there was a document that said
hey there's Kings and there's laws and
and and and and mr. John I don't know if
they even called him King John I mean
you probably I don't know you John
you're being a king and you're changing
the laws all the time you can't do that
now here's a document we're gonna call
it Magna Carta and and what we're gonna
say we're gonna put like with an arrow
to his chest I just imagine yeah you
know like sign it you are subject to the
law or you die here right and like that
that you know that that's severity that
founded Magna Carta amazing it was a
major step in modern law yeah so so and
when you start thinking about modern
governance you think about the Heritage
that that established the British Empire
right that also has heritage back to the
the knights of the round table and
holding this conversation in a circle -
with representation from the different
part of England right yeah that that
that much of that was codified in the
Magna Carta if you go to the National
Archives it kills every time I go there
our Constitution is on one side and
Magna Carta is on the other side same
room and there's all these documents all
the way through the room all the way
down so so so that so the next thing so
documents are interesting right because
there only is good they're only good if
people believe it but they but the thing
that they do is they codify a belief
right in a particular time in place
right so now unit Carter skip forward
British Empire colonialism good bad
every way that it happened is so
interesting that at any point a leader
could just change the code because there
was never a consensus goal congruence
within the civilization and then right
there was write codification right and
there you go and play the script check
the Portuguese check the Spanish check
the French during the colonial era and
check where the British ended up in
their scorecard
so now we've got another colony that
happened to be you know across the pond
there were 13 of them actually it was
not you know that kind of started where
you know you know one one vote came over
and hit Plymouth and another boat came
over and hit Jamestown so in in 60th at
so the first boat at Jamestown half of
us died second boat came half of us died
third boat came half of us well we
didn't die we figured out how to grow
corn that year we also figured out how
to grow tobacco and and and that put the
third leg in a global slave trade that
moved a significant amount of population
from Africa and slaved to the US most 12
and a half million people across from
Africa across Europe South America and
North America yeah and and those numbers
of millions and not in the 8 billion
people we have today right significant
significant numbers right so that
started because of what was going on in
Jamestown so in 1699 I was born and
raised in Williamsburg middle plantation
was changed to that they were still
dying of malaria in Jamestown middle
plantation was changed to Williamsburg
and that circle conversation was the
seat of government you can still go
there today and you can see the Capitol
building where they have a conversation
and you can see the governor's palace
down the corner that's three times the
size and it was wonderful for one guy
so so now here we are here we are a
little while later we're having these
other questions there's other things and
we write this you know actually Britain
you know like we know you're an empire
we know we're kind of small colonies but
in when in the order of human events it
has to come necessary for one people to
separate the political bonds that tie us
to another and you can read the the
Declaration of Independence that that
was given a declaration we are not your
colony anymore yeah and the war followed
right now we won that war you heard that
story but what's not really understood
is that is that after we won that war it
was like oh no now all the governance
problems that England had that were
subjugating we felt the pain of and now
we have to figure that out
and so that conversation that that was
that was that was developed in Virginia
and by this time the Virginia is a state
with a constitution of our own many many
many of the art of
that are in our US Constitution came out
of Virginia right and so that's right so
and so by that time Richmond was the
capital there's a lot of changes between
here and there but a constitution has
has so and I think when I think of
governance and I look at the document it
says that it says that a government of
the people by the people and for the
people shall not perish from the earth
forever but before that it says it says
that the purpose of government is to
provide for the common defense and
promote the general welfare right hmm so
and then and then to make sure that that
governance doesn't perish yes right so
it's like it's like it's like it's like
this this kind of conversation so here
we are 200 years later Virginia is 400
years old now we're in a three hundred
and sixtieth I believe 300 plus legisla
Wow so like put that in time scale Wow
and now let's go to cryptocurrency no
just Constitution on the blockchain so
then what are the principles that apply
right what how does common defense work
and how does general welfare work and
how does how does this add is this
everybody represented voice at work and
then and then the question there were
the real cool comment is is one of the
speakers here at Denton I might put the
link under for the for the recording mhm
she put on the screen now she was like
what does it mean to be activated as a
US citizen yeah yeah she puts SiC 50 30
or 50 links on the screen of all these
different places where you can dial on
to a website and speak directly to
somebody and have a direct impact on
what's happening in Washington DC yeah
yeah at your state level yeah right in
your local government congress.gov is a
great place to go to just be able to
read the legislation that is being
discussed in general yeah we still have
we still there's a lot of issues that I
want to own as an American citizen I
think that yes that's crucial to become
exactly to own these issues to take the
responsibilities from yourself that's
right exactly and not talk about rights
rights rights but instead talk about
responsibilities exactly and so you know
those rights are there emphatic and
another it like like it cannot be
removed and mainly in the bullish what
it said I in other words I'm an alien if
you take them away from me yeah turn
green in my eyes there's something I
want to before we keep getting into this
cuz this is really amazing I want to
just briefly touch on the
kind of in it's kind of insane when it
comes to the what would is actually
written in this code what is the code
itself because they're the kind of the
first thing about goal congruence in
terms of the future world that we're
building is we have to have some sort of
basic goal congruence and they're happen
they're worth the Magna Carta the
Declaration of Independence Constitution
this is this is a right and what is the
next hundred years what are the what is
the code for the next hundred years are
we going to write more so about morality
about not killing one another not
hurting one another working together
with one another all prospering together
how are we going to write these things
so we're gonna go back to what the
future and all the stuff we know about
it and one of the things we know that is
that we don't know what it looks like
yeah one of the things that we also know
about the future is that it's made up of
what's here today and so and so you know
like it's probably not very common there
there are many other nations that have
been around culturally a long time right
now the US has the longest standing form
of government that hasn't gone over some
major revision yeah we've got the
longest standing government on the world
in the world yeah that's amazing and so
and so I don't know like the answer is I
don't know but it's going to be a part
of this conversation and it's gonna be
definitely what's there right now yeah
there's there's a role in other words
there's a role and we have a role in
that in that progression as we go
forward so so yeah I think and that's
partially why I ask people if the US
should be a hegemony if we should lead
the world in the future development III
like to ask that question just been one
of the you know especially with what you
just said about us being the longest
standing 200 and whatever almost 40
years now and so when you say we I'd
like to constrain the we know we the
people yeah right yeah and and then I'd
like to point to the fact that you know
we're sitting here next to a beautiful
sculpture I'm looking at vineyards yes
and yeah this is like I mean we're we're
here in Yountville it's an amazing place
right yeah when I say do we have the
capacity to lead the world
citizens in the u.s. we've got a range
of capacity that much of the world
doesn't happen
yeah yeah from that sense of citizens I
said yes it's our role to get the world
as citizens as citizens yes and okay all
right this is this is maybe look the can
we can we maybe do it you said that
there's you almost you're being very
humble because you're very smart about
this but you're also smart enough to
know there's so much nuance that you
don't want to give a line of code yeah
so so I want to hear a line of code from
you of a line of a line of code about
what the Magna Carta should look like
moving forward into the future it should
be the same but mostly that that's what
I'm saying we'll see the same thing is
like this is like I'm not I'm that's why
I went that's why I started you asking
me about governance i I do platforms and
build missions for scientific inquiry
yes that's what I know I understand that
said yes there's a lot of people that
are that actually know what that code is
and they're expert at it yeah and so so
it's like you walk through Europe and
you think that all the buildings are
beautiful yeah it's like the ugly ones
were torn down like the way the way we
remember history is not the way it
happens right what is still there in the
code that that code that you're asking
for yeah I'm gonna go pull the old
document and understand what and why it
was said to be able to understand the
context I'm in now and use that as your
basis for my decisions going cool
correct but they're okay here let me
let's put it this way
you're smart enough to understand that
there are so many insanely societally
altering technologies that are occurring
today that were never conceived of 240
years ago or even 50 years ago for
shit's sake so now that we have genetic
engineering brain chips nanotechnology
AI robotics blockchain technology
cryptocurrencies these things are
becoming proliferated throughout society
in not necessarily closed environments
there what is the Magna Carta for those
things so so that's the challenge I'll
put that that's actually your challenge
in your domain if you're listening to
this that's actually your channel
I'll tell us why we talk about I'll tell
you what I've been doing in my domain to
answer that question and now I
understand what you're asking is is so
my job my day job so I've been at Co Fez
for 18 years in a 20 year organization a
20 year long event that's in a 25 to 30
year industry right I've been at NASA
for 12 years in a hundred-year-old
Center in a 400 year old state you know
and and so and so from that perspective
you know a lot of mine a lot of my
perspective on governance is informed by
the the craft of the cab industry mostly
yeah and one of the things that I've
observed is how things grow naturally
that there is a path there is a
progression and so the the my domain of
expertise is admissions and so I've been
seeking a governance model not not
centralized not even decentralized but a
mesh governance model where my in my
leadership has that my leadership that
elected by the people has the most
influence and I have the most control so
that so that that that because I the
best governance is what I just do what
I'm supposed to yeah we don't have to
wave it about taxes if all that happens
right yeah but unfortunately I don't
always do it I'm supposed to do and
that's why the cop is there right the
best governance is when we take on
responsibilities that's right ourselves
and roll on wrong pants right wake up
every morning and hustle that's love it
love it right okay and and you just do
everything you're supposed to and that's
not the human condition so it's not that
that is not congruent with the human
condition oh yeah people we I do bad
things
yeah once no yeah likewise yes and I
want somebody right there to tell the
shoulder help and if I don't listen to
the tap on the shoulder bring something
bigger yeah so so so when I'm trying to
understand in my area how do you develop
missions satellite missions in a
governance model when everything is
changing so fast and so and so what I've
been I found it I found a number of
things that are really interesting in
this study I've been in this I've been
in this journey for just in the small
satellite area for about five years now
like I said I started with wheels and
then I worked on wings so a robot with
an instrument
and then an airplane with an instrument
and now I'm working on this the solar
panels so the wheels wings and solar
panels is where they came from and so
now I'm working on these these
satellites with solar panels it's the
platform right and what I find is that
as I'm as I'm looking at you know I went
back again and did the history of
Langley and the instruments that the
major scientific breakthroughs where
there was a major shift in thought like
wow we can now do it this way like
testing materials on the International
Space Station is a Langley development
bringing an inflatable actually Elon
just launched today so maybe maybe we'll
actually be doing retropropulsion to the
surface of Mars but but before before we
did retropropulsion the expectation was
that you have a large inflated structure
falling to the surface of Mars before
that it was a heat shield right yeah so
Langley has also developed those yes yes
so so I went back and looked at all
these missions that that were developed
in this in this place of history right
in aerodynamics and then into space
right and then and I asked the question
what was what was necessary about the
first time it happened in other words
there was an opportunity there that
needed to be I'll say governed right now
or there needed to be some governance
model to fulfill that opportunity
adequately and then there's all these
ideas than that's everybody wonders
about the innovation they all talk about
the innovation so what was that right
and what I've noticed is that is that
the the the that that governance of how
those missions are selected we have to
call it mission natural selection AHA
it's it's iterative it's failure-prone
and and it's characterized and and and
what we know right now is that the model
says that there's an idea that precedes
a team
neither community starts to be building
around that team now now when the person
that had the idea was able to move with
the ideas different yeah I'm not we like
to say we started asking the question in
an environment dominated by intellectual
property what happens if we start
looking at
if I if ideas we're just giving away
it's not my problem yeah yeah yeah
exactly I've an ideas tab on my website
and I'm just like dude build these
things into the world if you like any of
they yeah so ideas really don't care
where they come from so so maybe the
person that had the idea isn't the right
one to carry exactly
maybe you build a team and build the the
marketing case and maybe you're not the
right you maybe that's not the right mix
to go get the money right but that idea
is gonna go and if you have any doubt
about this when was the last time you
worked all night on an idea that you had
you need to get the article out it yeah
yeah you didn't have that idea that idea
had you that caught that idea has like
slapped you silly and like sent you away
you know I go what's the path of the
idea yeah exactly the idea there's a
team that team generates and validates
and does all the work and then shows the
funding props there so idea team fund
and then somebody pays for it the
interesting thing is in most most the
time you want to know where that you're
what you're building works but if it's
for the first time you don't know who's
for the next step is you get the funding
then you build it and then you test it
so you build it not knowing if it's
gonna work then you test it and then you
fly it we just cut it sounds like ready
fire anyway so the question is can you
put it can you put a sort of a
scientific layer on top of that edge
type of governance model about how to
establish team under that idea team fun
build test fly most portfolios in the
world they want to pay for something
they want to see an idea they want to
fund it they want to build the team they
want to test it to make sure it works
then they want to build it then they
want to gonna fly it right yeah so so
idea fun team test build fly not idea
team fun build test block here so it's
different it was just that's to switch
there's two switches right those those
really those were interesting
observations that I've been looking at
to try and understand just my job right
from a governance standpoint just to
understand my job which is to build to
use small satellites against NASA
missions right and so so yeah so that's
that's what I've been doing in my neck
of the woods that that I I'm I'm
ambitious that it applies to technology
and how it works we've shown that it
works in a constrained environment in
one part of the world
in one technology small satellites right
yeah so so I'm thinking about governance
and does it apply to all technologies in
that same kind of context or does it
apply to that same type of technology in
all contexts or is applied to all
technologies in all contexts right
like those again that's why I said I'm a
systems engineer and I know the
boundaries the system I'm working in I
don't have a policy background either so
that's a whole nother that's a whole
nother question of that how does that
actually works there's a whole range of
questions beyond that but but yeah and
then the question is that the question
is you know in terms of getting active
in governance and and and like you talk
like you talked about like this goal
like this this this objective building
or the goals right there's huge huge
huge numbers of goals that are
everybody's setting and putting out
there you can go all the way up to the
the singular group on Earth Observation
as you know in the United Nations
function and we've got these global
sustainability objectives right and I'm
seeing the burnt Hills here in Napa the
recent fires here I talked to one guy he
said yeah and then it rained really hard
on the side of the hill that was just
burnt slid into the town it's like well
we know stuff is happening we don't like
are we making an effect on it would it
be happening any anyways did the Sun
just get angry and on the planets
heating up or our carbon it's our carbon
footprint affecting it like oh this is
this is the domain of the science and
the and the evidence is building and
mounting and I'm not gonna make a
comment on on on a position on that
that's a different conversation I do
have opinions on but but the point for
right now is is at the scale of can I
meet you know a small NASA like a local
Langley mission or can I meet a global
sustainability objective there's there's
governance questions at that scale and
they always come back to the individual
or we're gonna end up on the plains with
an arrow and a new letter saying signing
and it was the extreme cost with really
really high cost yes I don't want to see
that cause yeah I don't like that my
wife's an Air Force captain yeah so
we've done we've done two tours to Iraq
and one to Afghanistan yeah it's not a
good cost
yeah okay I guess so this now piggy
backs into kind of a point out we
definitely need a disco because
everything that you mentioned a second
ago is so spot on I don't see any flaw
with the way that you structured a idea
to the execution I thought that was very
beautiful coming from Silicon Valley
mm-hmm that is very beautifully said and
I really wish that more people followed
some sort of a similar path for I for
executing their ideas and also
understanding that the ideas being free
and this sort of roll with it exactly
this God how often do people just hold
on and just say that it's mines mines
right like let it be let it go to other
people they probably could do it better
etc if it's good enough all that kind of
stuff so I yeah there is some kind I do
have a comment on that yeah because
because because in an in in a world
where intellectual property is its
currency right and then you start giving
away money you can't it's very I am NOT
a fan of starting something before I
know why it should be started mm-hmm
yeah so and so the common course you
made there about it'd be great if all
the ideas were given away you know
you're bumping heart into a governance
issue absolutely and so and so the
challenge that the challenge that that
you hear me wrestling with is how do you
set it but how do you set up a structure
it's got to be it's got to be valued in
the like the same way we value
intellectual property it's got or the
same way we value clean air correct or
the same way that we value not wondering
if our our our bank account I don't know
if you have a Bitcoin wallet like your
you're much more tenuous about your
Bitcoin wallet than you are if you have
a account
had really six your bank right even
though there's you know anyways there's
a whole conversation there right but but
the question is do you have the
affordability of that and I lost the way
that where I was going take your second
let's see if we can find it
give me that
cryptocurrency and yeah oh yeah so so
the question so the question is do we
have do we have a way of when the new
cryptocurrency or whatever that new
technology comes do we have do we have a
high functioning model that replaces the
current governance metaphor before we
say oh the old one doesn't work mm-hmm
so that's the challenge for if you're if
you're really trying to seek out it you
know you want all these ideas to go away
we're a challenge that I'd give is to
and it's not like I have the idea it's
like I mean I've been wish the ideas
that I'm mentioning were shaped with
about 300 of my friends and colleagues
over five years right so this idea team
fun build test fly was like yeah it was
an open conversation we've been having
at NASA Langley Research Center for the
last half a decade right to try and
understand this this challenge in our
domain field right I don't want to say
it's wrong before I have a solution to
put in there and if I do it'll be just
the same as writing a Declaration of
Independence winning the war because we
will and then and then ending up and
it's like oh no what what does that
governance model look like what do we
how do we do that it's like well is
there a Virginia to point to and say hey
how does your constitution work okay
let's let's let's start with this we
have the Y the Y is first and we say the
Y is to progress civilization let's just
say that's the Y and then we figure out
the how and how are we doing that and
maybe that's where some of these codes
come into play now are you interested in
oh I have water for you thank you it's
one gesture that's gonna dry up very
very very quickly yes this make sure it
doesn't hit yeah yeah
and make sure it doesn't spit your
button either be like which is like this
is like the drawing yeah let's make like
let's make like are like a simulation or
something yeah so we've got over on this
side exactly like a drive yeah so just
let's let's let's do in as we move
forward or how do you put into balance
goal congruence across the planet u.s.
congruence but China congruence how do
they congroo that's that big question I
haven't really thought about that much
across the planet I know in the
technology sectors the the bit that we
started on about rights like there are
really fundamental rights that are that
are that are if you if they're not
respected the our humanity is in
question
like it and they're like our ability to
walk in the fullness like we've just
this amazing humanity is like just this
amazing vehicle with all these
capabilities and I know that if rights
are not respected there's a big issue
there right but the but the the bearing
of that burden and worthy you keep on
talking about like you know being you
know rights versus worth that
conversation responsibility yeah I like
carrying that responsibility you know I
really haven't thought a lot about what
that looks like across international
borders you you know mostly I'm just
trying to you know get my scientists and
I my engineers you know on the same
sheet of music with really different
values yes yeah so I can speak mistake I
can speak to that because I'm really
enjoy building teams yeah because so you
know when you start to bring these
different value systems in you end up
with you a much stronger solution than
you could have ever even imagined
and I said there's there's one thing
that I know about that that's
fundamental to that is is is that is
that you know good effective teams
because we're going back to not good or
bad with effective teams effective teams
talk about respect you talk about
communication mhmmm every team that I
come in come in to like what's the first
thing I hear them talking about and they
are they talking about the reason that
those people can't talk or the reason
that they say stupid stuff is that's
communication conversation I you know
there's a community that a team that I
just came in to and and the first thing
I heard about the team was wow he is an
amazing musician and you know like the
way he thinks about problems is yeah
exactly it's in respect yeah yeah and I
got into the team as I'm wading into the
team I'm like oh my god like this is not
good bad stuff saying it'd be like
saying something about China is good and
then China saying something about the US
is good yeah and it's having interesting
conversation about those things
respecting one another and our positions
in the world it's fundamental to human
yeah and and presidents across different
countries doing that and at the UN we do
that I know that's fundamental yeah
respect exactly yeah and that that comes
from there was I heard there was a
National Institute of Health wanted to
know what the number one epidemic in the
country that's a single-parent homes was
the an issue right and and there's all
these psychological issues that develop
and you don't have a healthy home and I
said well what they said well why does
that happen so net and IA asked the
National I'm sorry NIH asks the Gallup
that does you know I'm just insane
statistics I don't know they'll do
they'll they'll get a significantly
significant statistically significant
sampling and so they've really know like
like you know round long flat tall like
you know they just ask everybody right
the the this this architected well
architected instrument really its
scientific polling that's what Gallup
does yep Gallup came back and they said
well the reason that relationships don't
work NIH is because of bad communication
that's where they came from is like
that's why single-parent families have
because of that communication not a
respect and so NIH was like well we're
gonna send everybody to to communication
school just yeah yeah that's not the
answer it's like so they sent Gallup
back out and they said why is it what
why do they succeed then maybe then they
reframed it and this is happening at the
scale of like big science right and and
check me on the narrative for this this
is hearsay for me as a rocket scientist
right this is way out of my field and
they came back and they said hi you know
what interestingly enough just like bad
communication was singularly correlating
in other words all the factors the only
thing that lined up between all them
that failed was event communication all
the factors the only one that wind up
between successful relationships was
unrealistically high expectations of
your partner yeah no matter what happens
now you know right yeah yeah I know who
you are like it was a bad day for you
you're gonna be fine he's gone like what
exactly yeah you know you know I know
that I know that that that that that
flipped that huge a cruise missile was
there and I know it got launched but you
did pull it back I mean it was just
I know accidents happen and then that
applies to not only your business
relationship but your partner at home
that applies to your kids that teacher
the doctor whoever it is yeah but to
have goal congruence with them in
respect for one another
yeah yeah starts there it really starts
there so I wanna I wanna maybe we do a
quick ending on some of the like cosmic
conversation because because you you got
a you got a really great background for
this but you know we're figuring out how
to properly do EDL entry descent and
landing on to other planets and moons
and everything we're trying to really
figure that out how to colonize the
cosmos and and so so the way to go to
SpaceX and this domestic today for
sending a sports car on its way to Mars
yeah that's I know I know it's like love
it we definitely we definitely need some
robots to start building the habitation
I love it right so yeah yeah you're
right
we're in other words we're on the way
yeah it's a thing it's Sony so maybe
they'll provide us with a little bit of
your let's let's keep these punctual do
you think we're alone in the cosmos well
good lord I can say it's effective for
us to look
yeah I don't know I'd love to I mean
like why did crop circles happen like
you know there's all this stuff we don't
know and it's partly the domain of
science but it's just ignorance like we
just don't know I'm just uncomfortable
not know yeah I don't know I just be
comfortable not knowing yeah yeah and
it's and it's really a really really
really darn good idea to be looking yeah
it is a really good idea to be looking
otherwise how about you silly just be
chilling here just here it's so much
thing so how about are we in a computer
simulation are we in a computer
simulation let me check yeah yeah I
think so
are we in a computer simulation yeah
well the answer is 42 and the mice are
doing the experiment yeah no so so so I
don't know if we're if we're in a
computer simulation but I kind of like
this picture I was working on this
project and we're like trying to
understand like like big context one
small thing we can do I'm a big fan of
like I'm thinking down here and then
going home and doing one very small
thing that builds on one yeah yeah
exactly so we had this project we were
trying to span that bound right yeah and
I came as I were looking at how energy
moves through the planet yeah that's
amazing
came to this picture of this fireball
hurtling through this this like the sea
of intergalactic yeah yeah that's our
Sun and and and and and and just like
we're like riding its wake on the
speedboat earth food and and almost on a
lake right and these waves of solar
radiation are washing a little yeah yeah
it's a really good way to look at it and
we're bouncing and the and and the Sun
changes the Sun will like make a little
Burpo like burp out a black hole and
then the earth also a burp out the
earthquake this dynamic system right and
and and and and and and I had a friend
say you know it's you're beautiful if we
were thinking about spaceship earth and
and and estimation birth scripts so and
so the good news is we are on a
spaceship it's got a great life support
system there's a really good party going
on and and and I mean and I'm really
loving Yountville and and and the thing
that's interesting is that there is a
control panel
there's a control panel and and that
control panel like like like the Sun
hits the ocean it warms up and the heats
up the air moisture goes in it comes
over and it rains and that's a control
loop right and this it's almost science
is a major part of the control panel and
maybe also a spiritual 'ti all of his
energy yeah I love the control panel on
let's like like I say shipper right
there is a control panel right there is
a control panel that is driving this
thing and we have a more significant
representation on the spaceship than
ever before yeah and and so and so the
the picture that comes to mind is we've
got the spaceship here's the Sun it's
got a control panel the parties great
and back to governance everybody that
should be operating the controls is
trying to calm down the party instead of
driving the ship and so when we're
thinking about these things we're
thinking about these issues of
governance like why is what's going on
with the plastic in the ocean
what's going on with the carbon budget
what's going on with all these different
things right and these all come down to
governance and so so what I'd say what
I'd say in all seriousness is you know
if we like spaceship earth in the
life-support system that it has and the
party that we have going on but let's
not make it one party or another and
let's make sure that the people that
actually have the capacity to be at the
controls don't have to keep on fighting
a party to keep the party from from tip
over yeah so that party needs to work
together with the controls and
symbiotically intertwine and work on it
okay and by party I mean people party is
people exactly people are having a party
yeah a great life support system on the
spaceship earth yeah all right so that
amazing conversation very
interdisciplinary I'm serious that's why
you know I love chatting with you it's
always so good I'm excited for your
future what you're gonna be building to
be a part of coefficient moving forward
to be a part of more of what NASA
Langley Research is doing you guys are
amazing and guys thanks for tuning in we
really appreciate you so much as well
again you're visiting simulation I'm
with Nathaniel Miller
we have Ronald Vargas as our director
behind the
always crushing it always doing a great
job we have our if you guys had a good
time please do like please comment
please subscribe also feel free to join
as a member of our patreon you get
exclusive benefits like exclusive
content you get access to asking our
guest priority questions you get access
to live events you get access to all of
this great stuff becoming a member to do
please consider and share and is there a
way to follow you on twitter i'm on am
on twitter at be la k sk y BL a KS KY we
will put you know like black sky right
now right in the bio and we'll put some
more links to what we were describing as
well in the bio so thank you guys again
for tuning in thank you for thanks so
much
i'll be on the show and thanks for
watching awesome thanks guys yeah it was
a blast